[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 28
octobre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 78 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
l'actualité locale accompagnée de nos
invités ainsi que des journalistes de la
rédaction on commence tout de suite avec
les titres de cette
édition lors de son déplacement au
Mureau au début de la semaine le Premier
ministre a annoncé une série de
nouvelles mesures pour les banlieux et
notamment la mise en place de délégués
gouvernementaux chargés en lien avec le
maire de redonner force et cohérence à
l'action publique locale trappe fait
partie des trois villes déjà
sélectionnées en colère contre la
réforme de l'aide juridictionnel les
avocats poursuivent leurs actions nous
ferons le point avec Maître Pierre
bordesou de Bellefeuille président de la
section versaillaise des syndicats des
avocats de France et enfin la joueuse
professionnelle de softball Megan Willis
qui évolue en Floride dans le
championnat américain de pass en France
pour un atelier découverte elle était
hier avec les coupgards de Montini le
Bretonneux et c'est la deuxième fois
qu'il fait le déplacement en Siri
Jean-Frédéric Poisson député des ivlines
président du parti chrétiendémocrate est
actuellement au côté de Bachar alAssad
un déplacement avec deux autres députés
de droite pour échanger sur le conflit
actuel il n'appartient pas au pays
étrangers de décider qui doit diriger la
Syrie il appartient au syriens de décid
a déclaré celui qui par ailleurs se
présente à la primaire organisée par la
droite en vue de la présidentielle de
2017 des rencontres avec le vice
ministre des Affaires étrangères du pays
ou encore le grand moufti de Damas sont
prévus bien que le qu d'orset
désapprouve les visites du parlementaire
français et vous que pensez-vous de ce
déplacement faut-il garder des liens
diplomatiques avec laassyrie c'est notre
question du jour regardez c'est
important qu'il a des personnes comme ça
justement qui voilà qui fassent la
transition et nous transmettent ce qui
se passe aussi ailleurs pour mieux
comprendre beaucoup de choses bah tout
seul c'est un peu il rien faire le pvre
monsieur ça nous coûte de l'argent c'est
qui qui paye ça c'est contribuable c'est
pas le rôle d'un député local parce que
normalement d'appliquer une politique
qui est la politique qui est choisie au
niveau national par le Président de la
République ou par le truc comme ça quo
quoi qu'il en soit de quel bord qu'on
soit mais je ne sais pas si c'est son
rôle mais je Seris d'accord qu' qu'il le
fasse pourquoi pas si ça doit amener des
améliorations et si ça doit amener
des éléments un peu un peu plus
pacifiques actuellement pourquoi pas et
Jean-Frédéric Poisson sera l'invité de
la rédaction ce ce vendredi dans le
journal présenté par Wilfried Richy et
enfin je vous le disais en titre le 26
octobre dernier lors du comité
interministériel à l'égalité à la
citoyenneté le Premier ministre a
annoncé de nouvelles mesures concernant
les quartiers d' défavorisés notamment
la nomination de délégués du
gouvernement sur 10 sites pilotes pour
faire émerger de nouvelles méthode de
travail en lien avec le préfet et le
maire porter volontaire la ville de
trappe fait partie de ces communes qui
expériment prochainement ce nouveau
dispositif les explications avec William
l cette nouvelle mesure vient compléter
la mise en œuvre du contrat de ville une
dizaine de sites pilotes vont bientôt
expérimenter une démarche partenariale
avec l'État annoncé le 26 octobre par le
Premier ministre la nomination de
délégués du gouvernement qui
travailleront en lien avec le préfet et
le maire il aura l'autonomie nécessaire
notamment budgétaire pour mobiliser les
ressources du territoire administration
comme association afin de battir de
manière réactive et créative des
solutions sur mesure pour obtenir des
résultats tangibles pour les habitants
l'objectif redonner force et cohérence à
l'action publique locale pour cette
mission l'état travaillera conjointement
avec le Conseil national des Villes
récemment réorganisé sont concernés par
cette opération 17 quartiers sur 10
villes pilotes dont la commune de trappe
je pense des décisions en ce qui
concerne les services extérieurs de
l'État les mises en place de financement
et puis la la mobilisation si je peut
dire du partenariat qu'on a avec avec pô
emploi la CA d'allocation familiale avec
les différents bailleurs ce dispositif
interviendra sur des projets spécifiques
dans des quartiers identifiés localement
comme prioritaires des moyens
d'intervention dédiés seront mobilisés
et les habitants du quartier seront
associés à chaque étape du processus en
ce qui concerne les les points d'appui
par particulier et puis le
renouvellement urbain ça conserne Camu
Vedrine et et la cité nouvelle pour le
moment aucun budget n'est encore dévoilé
une feuille de route avec le nom des
personnalités missionnées sera remise
avant la fin de l'année un premier bilan
sera réalisé d'ici un an et nous allons
à présent parler de la mobilisation des
avocats nous sommes en plateau avec
Maître Pierre bordessou de Bellefeuille
président des syndicats des avocats de
de France pour la section Versailles
bonsoir à vous et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors nous sommes ici
pour parler de la grève des avocats mais
dans les vines ils sont mobilisés euh
déjà la semaine dernière lundi il y
avait une première mobilisation est-ce
que vous pouvez expliquer en en somme
les les causes de cette mobilisation ah
alors la manifestation de lundi
répondait à quelque chose d'un peu
spécifique puisqu'il y a une dizaine de
jours il y a eu des confrères qui se
sont fait molester à lîle qui ont été
traînés par terre un bâtonnier a été
ceinturé c'était des avocats qui
manifestaient dans leur juridiction
pacifiquement paisiblement et tout à
fait légalement on croyait que cet
événement serait unique il ne l'a pas
été puisquil y a eu des événements
péible à Toulouse où cette fois-ci de
nouveau des avocats qui ne n'étaient
absolument rien agressif ont été gazés
il y a une quinzaine d'avocats qui ont
été gazés dont trois qui ont dû faire
l'objet de soins médicaux et ça s'est
encore renouvelé à Boulogne où le même
bâtonnier de lîle qui avait été ceinturé
deuxème fois été molesté ça n'était
jamais arrivé jusque-là dans l'histoire
de de la République donc les avocats
présents puisque nous sommes en période
de fête au Barreau de Versailles ont
voulu marquer le coup et derrière leur
bâtonniers avec les syndicats et avec
tous les avocats qui ont pu être
présents il y a eu une première
manifestation
d'indignation sincèrement on pensait que
le phénomène serait unique et on
s'aperçoit qu'il s'est inscrit dans une
série d'événements qui sont extrêmement
fâcheux ça fait donc 3 semaines que le
mouvement est lancé pour vous c'est une
provocation du gouvernement de réagir
comme ça par rapport à cette
mobilisation je ne suis pas à la place
du gouvernement mais et je ne peux que
rapprocher quelques circonstances nous
sommes en train à l'heure actuelle au
Sénat de discuter du budget de la
justice et et ce débat commence au Sénat
et dans les heures qui suivent le début
de ce débat on voit des violences qui
n'avait jamais été exercé jusque-l c'est
vrai que il y avait une prise de
position qui avait été faite par le
Conseil national des barreaux pour la
grève je dois avouer que la l'attitude
du gouvernement en matière de
négociation est tout à fait singulière
envoyer des serrait sur des avocats qui
veulent dialoguer qui veulent continuer
à dialoguer avec la Chancellerie ça ne
s'est jamais vu je crois effectivement
que madame la garde des saau ou le
gouvernement a passé un certain cran il
y a eu des robes qui ont été déchirées à
lî je me rappelle de l'indication je
d'indignation je crois de notre premier
ministre quand on avait déchiré la robe
d'un personne personne chargée de
relations humaines à Air France pour pas
le dire il n'y a pas eu que je sache de
la part de Monsieur Vals un mot d'excuse
pour ces violences commises envers des
gens qui travaillent dans un tribunal et
qui ont été agressés aux portes de leur
palais de justice dans le cadre de
revendication qui leur semble tout à
fait légitime dans l'intérêt des
justiciables plus que des avocats du
reste alors revenons également sur les
causes du mouvement il est dû notamment
la réforme proposée par Christian tobira
et adopté jeudi dernier par les députés
alors c'est l'aide juridictionnelle donc
l'aide juridictionnelle c'est ce que
c'est voilà ce ce s quoi vous vous
mobilisez c'est une aide financière de
l'État pour les plus déminis qui ne
peuvent pas se payer un avocat
lorsqu'ils sont parties prenantes d'une
procédure judiciaire donc cette aide
jici va être complètement remanié et
vous n'êtes pas d'accord justement avec
la façon dont cela va être remanié elle
ne va pas être profondément remaniée on
pensait qu'effectivement elle serait
profondément remagé et qu'il y aurait
une adaptation par exemple des
indemnisations par rapport au nombre
d'heures de travail ça n'est absolument
pas le cas on a le sentiment qu'on va
réduire là où il y a le plus de
contentieux et où est-ce qu'il y a le
plus de contentieux c'est dans les
accidents de la vie ça va être dans un
divorce le juge aux affaires familiales
ça va être dans une expulsion conseil
des prudom
exulsion tribunal d'instance ou un
licenciement conseil des prudomes ce
sont les trois domaines qui sont le plus
touchés c'est là où il y a plus de
réduction autrement dit on en vient à
considérer que les accidents de la vie
doivent mériter quasiment le moins
d'indemnisation possible je parlais tout
à l'heure de l'expulsion devant le
tribunal d'instance l'indemnisation qui
est prévue au bénéfice d'abord du
justiciable puisque c'est lui qui
remplit la demande est de l'ordre de 150
€ alors qu'avant elle était de l'ordre
de 300 € 150 € ça do être 2hures de
garagiste quand vous avez un accident de
voiture votre véhicule est gravement
endommagé je disais que j'étais dans le
cadre d'une expulsion c'est quand même
un accident très grave vous iriez voir
un garagiste en lu disant voici les clés
de ma voiture n'y passez pas plus de 2
heures donc concrètement les avocats qui
vont défendre voilà ce genre de cas qui
sont commis d'office vont être moins
payés ils vont être ils étaient déjà
indemnisés je pense pas qu'on puisse
parler de paiement on a abouti à des
calculs sur le barreau de Paris par
exemple en matière de garde à vue en
matière de garde- à vue nuit et jour
365 jours de l'année vous avez des
avocats qui sont disponibles au barreau
de Paris ils sont amusés à calculer la
nouvelle indemnisation combien ça ferait
et bien ça ferait 7 € de l'heure je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il y ait sur ce plateau
de télévision où à l'écoute sur vos
téléspectateurs beaucoup de gens qui
accepteraient de travailler pour 7 € de
l'heure pendant 48 he puisqu'il est
question d'une
forfaitarisation de la garde à vue VO
donc voici donc le genre de résultat
auquel on aboutit on a des dossiers au
titre de l'aide juridictionnelle ou de
la commission d'office qui seront
déficitaires mais au-delà de tout ce
qu'on avait auparavant il s'agit d'une
imputation sur ces trois accidents de la
vie que j'ai cité qui sont le divorce
l'expulsion de son domicile le
licenciement c'est plusieurs dizaines de
pourcents de réduction qui sont prévu
par le ministère vous comprenez que à
travers nous à travers nos robes
déchirées à travers nos bâtonniers
molestés quelque part c'est le
justiciable à qui on vient dire mais
votre dossier n'est pas sérieux il
mérite pas plus que 2 heures de vous
pensez que là ça êre justifiable qui a
vraiment du coup embêté par cette
situation qui va vraiment subir les
conséquences quand vous aurez plus de
garagiste pour réparer votre véhicule
effectivement votre véhicule restera
dans la rue à l'heure actuelle vous avez
près de 900000 et on va sans doute
passer un million de personnes qui
peuvent bénéficier de cette aide
juridictionnelle quand il y aura plus
d'avocats qui seront plus intéressés
pour travailler à 7 de l'heure et bien
vous aurez plus personne dans les
commissariats vous n'aurez plus non plus
peu personne pour assurer la défense des
plus démunis c'est soi-disant une
affaire de gros sous vienent nous dire
dire ceux qui n'ont pas très bien
compris la chose non c'est d'abord un
service que l'on rend au justiciables et
que l'on annonce encore plus déficitaire
qu'il ne l' à l'heure actu actuellement
les rapports parlementaires y compris
issus de de la majorité actuelle parlait
d'un doublement de de des indemnisations
actuelles et là on a une augmentation
annoncée de 7 % inférieure au taux de la
vie de 10 % depuis 2007 puisque
l'indemnisation n'avait pas été
réactualisée depuis 2007 sincement ça
n'est pas très sérieux vous disiez que
vous vouliez continuer le le dialogue
justement avec la ministre des saau
qu'est-ce que vous proposez du coup pour
voilà pour Cece qu'il a quand même des
économies à faire dans le contexte
économique actuel et on peut pas trop
faire autrement alors les économies on
les fait et les sacrifices on les fait
puisqueeectivement vous avez une aide
indirecte qui est faite pour l'aide
juridictionnelle pour la commission
d'office puisque les avocats participent
à tout le processus et on peut évaluer
ça peut-être 10 millions 15 millions
d'euros ça a été fait donc d'ors et déjà
les avocats font du sacrifice ils ont
fait des sacrifices aussi quand on leur
a dit de s'informatiser ils sont
informatisés et puis quand il y a une
loi qui leur a demandé de se former ils
se sont formés et maintenant on vient
leur demander encore plus et les idées
elles ne manquent pas et c'est pour ça
qu'on ne comprend pas la chancellerie et
qui qui a une attitude qui est
totalement sans aucun rapport avec les
propositions qui ont été faites je crois
que toute votre émission ne suffirait
pas pour énoncer les possibilités
d'action mais il y en a quelques-unes et
je ne citerai pas celle pour laquelle je
suis je vais vous les citer en vrac il y
a une partie des professions juridiques
judiciaire qui ne font pas de commission
d'office ou de garde à vue peut-être
qu'il pourrait y avoir cette forme de
solidarité exprimée par d'autres
profession que les avocats il y a les
contrats d'assurance juridique il avait
été question d'une taxation des contrats
d'assurance juridique peut-être
serait-elle à développer il y a
énormément de pistes et c'est pour ça
qu'on a peut-être été extrêmement naïf
car on pensait que ces dizaines de
pistes qui existent avec la
collaboration de tout le monde pouvait
aboutir avec un petit peu de bonne
volonté et certainement pas avec des
tonf et avec des et bien nous suivrons
donc cette actualité et la mobilisation
qui va justement continuer en attendant
une réponse de Madame la Ministre des
saut merci Pierre maître Pierre bordesou
de d'être venu avec nous en plateau et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je vous
remercie et depuis quelques jours la
commune de rambouiller et RDF ont ancé
une première phase de travaux pour
améliorer la desserte électrique de
plusieurs lieux de la commune ces
travaux sont tout près de la National 10
et ce chantier utilise une technique
souterraine et peu connue ce matin un
forage de 95 était réalisé Mélan poqu
était sur place
regardez à quelques mètres seulement de
la route nationale 10 au niveau de
Rambouillet des travaux sont en cours
rien d'inhabituel si ce n'est la
technique employée sur ce chantier il
s'agit d'un forage dirigé c'est une
technique qui est beaucoup plus dis
discrète qu'un qu'un qu'une tranchée
classique c'est également sur le plan du
développement durable un atout puisque
il y a pas on n pas enlevé
des les les terres avec des camion en
général donc il a il y a du CO2 qui se
qui se qui qui est utilisé à cette
occasion là la tige passe environ 3 M50
sous la nationale le chantier évite
ainsi la fermeture de la circulation
d'un axe routier primordial pour la
commune de Rambouillet et ses alentours
les gravas eux sont ensuite aspirés donc
de sécuriser un petit peu l'aspect
humain et l'aspect des travaux d'accord
puisque on détecte exactement où sont
situé les têtes et à ce titre là on
respecte également le décret entier
endommagement des réseaux le
bénéficiaire de cette partie du chantier
le centre de loisirs du château d'eau de
la commune il accueille 170 enfants un
chantier comme ça c'est fondamental
puisque le centre de loisir est
complètement refait là où il se trouve
c'est la possibilité d'avoir une
centaine d'enfants sur ce site et c'est
forcément là où où le lieu dans lequel
il est bâti il est construit qui est
proche de la forêt c'est quelque chose
de fondamental le tronçon réalisé
aujourd'hui représente un investissement
de 200000 € de la part de RDF en tout 8
km de câble de 20000 V seront remplacés
d'ici le début de l'année 2016 pour un
coût de 2 million
d'euros connaissez-vous le softball
c'est un sport dérivé du baseball qui
est très populaire en Amérique du Nord
et ce sont surtout les femmes qui le
pratiquent hier à Montini le Bretonneux
la sportive américaine megéan Willis
star du softball a participé à un
atelier c'était un événement la
floridienne a donné à cette occasion
quelques conseils et astuces reportage
de Michel elmidoro et Elodie
moine l'américaine Megan Willis 30 ans
est l'une des meilleures joueuses de
softball au monde l'équivalent du
baseball pour les féminines au pays de
l'Oncle Sam ce mardi la joueuse
professionnelle a animé un atelier avec
des jeunes au stade de jeanméchal de
montig Bretonneux pour présenter son
sport au programme de la frappe des
sessions pour rattraper la et de la
défense c'était une journée très
spéciale aujourd'hui c'était important
pour moi d'être là et de voir autant de
jeunes garçons et de jeunes filles
c'était vraiment fantastique de les voir
jouer au softball et au baseball
ensemble en France m' dit
comment on se plçait en Catur et comment
on se plçait pas en
Catur et plein d'autres choses cette
rencontre exceptionnelle a été rendue
possible grâce à un partenariat entre la
Fédération Française de basball et
l'ambassade des États-Unis c'est
exceptionnel parce que on a une athlète
exceptionnelle et et ce qui est
important c'est de saisir encore une
fois ces opportunités pour montrer à nos
jeunes à nos licenciés en général
d'ailleurs ce ce qu'est vraiment le
softball et pas simplement une démarche
franco-française c'est vraiment ce qu'on
a de mieux aujourd'hui sur le softball
mondial on l'a ici à Montini au total
plus de 60 joueurs de baseball et de
softball se sont inscrits à la session
pour avoir la chance d'être coaché par
la floridienne
waouh bah du coup moi j'ai posé mon
après-midi et ce que je me suis dit je
pense enfin avoir l'occasion de
rencontrer une joueuse américaine
professionnel je pense on aura pas
beaucoup l'occasion dans une vie donc
donc j'ai sauté sur l'occasion et c'est
c'est super certaines filles ont le
potentiel pour intégrer l'équipe
nationale peut-être que l'une d'entre
elles aura l'opportunité de participer
aux Jeux olympiques de 2020 la tournée
de Méan Wily en France s'achèvera fin
octobre après Montin Bretonneux
l'américaine participe des ateliers
softball à Lyon et à
Bordeaux et à France Miniature durant
ces vacances de la toussin rène comme un
petit a d'Halloween un petit peu avant
l'heure les chemins du parc sont en
vaill de citrouille et les dimanches des
personnages étranges Rudent dans les
allées étranges mais il ne sont pas si
effrayants ils font des tours de magie
inspirés des différents lieux du parc
Mélanie poket et Elodie
moine halloween c'est dans quelques
jours et pourtant les monstres sont déjà
là des monstres pas si méchants que ça
et dotés de pouvoir pas for il y a
différents thèmes on va sur Paris on se
fait guillotiner on va vers le côté du
roi Artru en Bretagne on va dire du côté
de la forêt de brossellliande et puis là
il se passe des choses curieuses avec
une épée magique il va falloir la
retirer mais pas forcément la retirer la
rcher le retirer d'un coup
incompréhension timidité ou
émerveillement les tours de passe-pe des
magiciens de l'association fonctionnent
j'aime bien la magie parce que c'est
surprenant il y a plutôt des choses
efficace par
exemple le suspense qu'estce qu'il va
faire quand je vois mes enfants ébaill
comme ça en train de regarder les les
jeux les tests franchement
ENF les animations des magiciens c'est
magnifique c'était sympa aussi de voir
il y a des enfants qui font la magie
puis de me dire que ils ont dû commencer
tôt pour faire ça et puis ils font bien
la mise en scène et tout c'était drôle
les tours de magie à France Miniature ce
n'est pas terminé prochain rendez-vous
pour découvrir dimanche 1er novembre la
bonne
carte et on a parfois tendance à se
tromper sur la date alors le 1er
novembre c'est le jour de tous les
saints et le jour des défuns c'est le 2
novembre donc lundi prochain à cette
occasion certains d'entre nous iront
dans les cimetières pour rendre hommage
au défuns ou encore fleurir les pierres
tombales la fleur la plus plébisitée
c'est bien souvent le crisantthème pour
en parler avec nous ce soir en plateau
Mélanie poquet bonsoir Mélanie alors le
Crison thème est-il vraiment la fleur du
deuil alors pour la France oui le crisen
thème est la fleur la plus achetée en
cette période c'est cette fleurs vendu
sur 10 selon une synthèse de France
agriè c'est l'établissement national des
produits de l'agriculture et de la mer
la synthèse porte sur l'année 2014
chaque année il y a plus de 21 millions
de pots de crisenthème qui sont vendu et
toutes fleurs confondu la période de la
toussin il y a près de 9,6 millions de
foyers français qui achètent des
végétaux ça représente un marché de 287
millions d'euros alors est-ce que ça a
été toujours la fleur la plus plébicitée
et d'où vient cette tradition Mélanie
alors c'est assez récent parce que le
crisantè est devenu la fleur des morts
en 1919 Raymond pocarré est alors
président de la République et il exige
que tous les monuments au Morts de
France soient fleuris et la décision du
président a facilité les sort du
crisanthème il y a une petite chose à
savoir Floren c'est qu'il n'y a qu'en
France que le chisanthème a cette notion
mortuaire en Asie d'où il est originaire
c'est un symbole d'éternité de grandeur
et d'excellence alors pourquoi cette
fleur est si appréciée en cette période
par les Français alors c'est avant tout
une question de résistance au temps par
rapport à la plante je me suis rendue
chez Marianne Denis elle est fleuriste à
saincir l'école bah déjà première chose
c'est quand même une fleur de saison
même si on en trouve toute l'année
l'automne c'est quand même la saison du
chrysanthème autant on peut l'utiliser
aussi pour décorer le parvis de sa
maison aux couleurs de l'automne autant
c'est quand même plus largement utilisé
pour fleurir les cimetières parce que
c'est quand même résistant euh il y a de
multiples fleurs sur un même pied donc
c'est vrai que du coup ça perdure le
temps que les fleurs se renouvellent et
cetera ça il y a une notion quand même
de temps alors il y a deux sortes de
crisanthème les grosses têtes ou les
pomponnettes les pomponnettes c'est des
petites fleurs qui ornent les plantes on
peut les acheter en bouquet ou en peau
et c'est souvent la deuxième solution
qui est privilégiée par les Français par
contre si la fleur est résistante elle
mérite quand même de l'attention des
petits conseils de notre
fleuriste il faut l'entretenir au sens
l'arroser bien sûr mais aussi veiller à
enlever les feuilles fanées ainsi que
les fleurs fanées pour que la floraison
dure le plus longtemps possible un
crisantième bien entretenu ça peut durer
très longtemps quand même quelques mois
peut-être bon après faut vraiment bien
l'entretenir mais bon je pense que c'est
quand même assez résistant alors faut
avoir la main verte mais si on souhaite
changer du crisantème est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres plantes que l'on peut choisir
oui bien sûr mais comme toujours avec
les végétaux le choix se fait par
rapport à la saison par contre si vous
voulez éviteer le fameux crisanthème il
y a toujours les roses les asalé ou les
bruyères ces dernières sont d'ailleurs
les deuxièmes plantes les plus vendus à
cette période là aussi ces plantes sont
résistantes elles apprécient l'humidité
automnale mais ce qu'il faut faire
Floran c'est surtout écouter ses
préférences ou se rappeler celle du
disparu parce que la toussin c'est avant
tout une fête personnelle merci merci
beaucoup Mélanie et des fleurs
automnales il y en a aussi dans les
jardins du château de Versailles le
château de Versailles qui ouvre
l'exposition tant attendu de la
programmation de cette année dans le
cadre du tricentenaire de la mort de
Louis XIV vous pourrez profiter de cette
exposition intitulée Le Roi est mort
jusqu'au 21 février 2016 Sephora Namani
et Patrick Jacques de dixmud l'ont vu
pour nous
regardez draperie noire tapisserie faon
brocard reconstitution du grand cénotaf
et jeu de lumière une scénographie
baroque exceptionnelle pour la nouvelle
exposition au château de Versailles le
roi est mort cette exposition accorde à
la scénographie une une place toute
particulière parce que elle est tout à
fait dans l'esprit de ce que c'était car
toute la cérémonie les cérémonies
funèbres de Louis XIV ont été organisées
par l'administration des menus plaisir
et c'était des décor éphémè des costumes
éphémères tout était fait pour la
cérémonie pour ce temps de
cette exposition permet de mettre en
lumière la mort de Louis XIV survenue le
1er septembre 1715 mettant fin au plus
long règne de la monarchie française de
l'autopsie au funéraille du Roi Soleil
en passant par l'étiquette du deuil à la
cour tout le protocole y est détaillé
les règles du deuil étaient les
suivantes une couleur la plupart du
temps c'est le noir ce qui est plus
important c'est la nature des vêtements
c'est tout ceci est très codifié et
notamment euh la la longueur par exemple
la longueur du manteau c'est les
attributs qu'on portent les
épées les livres que l'on tient à la
main les éventails les coiffures les
bijoux tous ces détails dépendent de
deux choses cela dépend de la personne
pour qui on porte le deuil et ça dépend
de la personne qui porte le deuil la
mort du Roi Soleil marque la fin de 72
ans d'absolutisme royal et offre la
possibilité aux idées nouvelles du
siècle des Lumières de se développer les
premiers pflet vont faire leur
apparition la mort de Louis XIV c'est la
le début de la chute des Jésuites en
France et c'est important c'est la fin
d'un gouvernement personnel et très
autoritaire plus de latitude plus de
tolérance plus de possibilités dans le
domaine de l'édition et de la presse il
sera possible de profiter de cette
exposition très riche en information au
château de Versailles jusqu'au 21
février
2016 et c'est la fin de cette édition je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi je
vous donne rendez-vous demain à 18h pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 journal en
direct tout de suite vous avez
rendez-vous avec Sephora Namani et ses
invités pour un nouveau numéro de CUS
que je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée